eigentlich will Horst bandmann Offizier
werden er möchte fliegen stattdessen
wird der 19-Jährige fanrecht zum
aussichtslosen Straßenkampf nach Berlin
geschickt seine Einheit besteht neben
ihm nur noch aus einer Gruppe Jungs aus
der Hitlerjugend am 22 April werden sie
von russischen Panzern angegriffen Horst
bandmann überlebt doch um ihn herum
überall tote und Palette er ist
plötzlich alleine und irrt ohne ein
bestimmtes Ziel durch die zerstörten
Straßen von Berlin
lebensgefährlich nicht nur wegen der
herabstürzenden Trümmer oder der
russischen Angreifer Patrouillen der SS
suchen nach wie vor nach Deserteuren
hi stehen bleiben
ich will versprengt meine Einheit
aufgerieben wo soll das gewesen sein
in der Nähe des Bahnhofs Weißensee
gestern
Weißensee
könnte schön wo wollen Sie jetzt hin
keine Ahnung muss doch irgendwo eine
Truppe geben die mich noch brauchen kann
sie wollen sich jetzt nicht zufällig
verkrümeln in luftauflösen ganz bestimmt
nicht
sofort im reissluftministerium
Wilhelmstraße da gibt es eine
Sammelstelle für versprenkte zu Befehl
machen Sie keine Umwege für mich wir
werden das nachprüfen in dieser Tür beim
Plünderer wird mit aller Härte
vorgegangen
sind die wandern jawohl erläutert
sie übernehmen sofort eine Gruppe von
drei Unteroffizieren und 24 Mann
sie haben glücksfähnrich das sind
überwiegend erfahrene Frontsoldaten zum
Teil mit hohen Auszeichnungen ich weiß
dass ihre Kampferfahrung begrenzt ist
aber in dieser Situation ist jeder
Soldat über dich hinauswachsen da habe
ich sie etwas fragen Herr Leutnant wozu
stimmt es dass der Reichsmarschall
Göring sich seit einigen Tagen nicht
mehr in Berlin befindet
der Reichsmarschall hat vom Führer
wichtige Aufgabe in Süddeutschland
bekommen und wir kämpfen hier noch
erläutert
verstehen Sie mich bitte nicht falsch
ich bin kein Feigling und auch kein
Deserteur aber ich muss wissen warum wir
noch kämpfen
nageln
die wir hatten überhaupt ja und die
anderen Taschen voller Munition haben
wir uns gebracht Handgranaten haben wir
gekriegt eierhandgranaten Panzerfäuste
nachts um zwei bin ich mit denen dann
abmarschiert ich habe dann den Befehl
gekriegt Richtung
Andreasstraße Frankfurter Allee Ecke
Blumenstraße dort Frankfurter Allee das
ab zu schirmen und zu sichern dass der
Russe da nicht durchkommt aber das hier
schafft hätten kann ich heute nicht
sagen
sofort rauskommen
nicht schießen
wir haben da natürlich ein bisschen
es waren Mehl Zucker und was ist alles
noch gab da haben wir geklaut und über
uns um zu leben wir haben hier auch
laufen lassen wir haben dann nicht
mitgemacht wir mussten ja selbst sehen
worüber bleiben ich habe zum Beispiel
mir dann mein Kochgeschirr mit Bonbons
Folie macht das war meine Nahrung und
was anderes hatten wir nicht
als plötzlich nur wenige Meter neben ihm
eine Granate einschlägt wird Horst
bandmann verletzt Splitter durchbohren
seinen Unterschenkel auf einem Jeep wird
er schließlich ins Rote Rathaus ins
Notlazarett gebracht das
sieht gar nicht so schlimm aus ach was
verstehst du denn davon Mädchen das
Mädchen heißt Jutta besser als ein
Bauchschuss ist das auf jeden Fall
dann kommt der Arzt haben wir nicht
kriegen wir auch nicht mehr
brauchst du doch jetzt nicht mehr oder
haben mit der Munition
ich bin alt genug
was habe ich gemacht ich habe es ihm
alles gegeben ich war froh dass ich los
war hätte ich nie machen sollen aber
in dem Moment dachte ich was sollst du
damit noch das war eindeutig die Jungs
waren ja alle so von der Erziehung her
fanatisiert dass er das noch nie
geglaubt haben die haben das auch noch
nicht geglaubt das ist schluss ist in
der Nacht zum zweiten Mai Gerät Horst
bandmann in sowjetische
Kriegsgefangenschaft es dauert noch
einige Monate bis seine kriegsverwundung
geheilt ist und der wieder laufen kann
aufgrund seiner Jugend wird bandmann
wenig später entlassen nach einem
Architekturstudium bringt es bandmann in
der DDR auch ohne Parteizugehörigkeit
bis zum Oberingenieur